hallo wir sind heute am flughafen wohin
fliegen wir ja nichts wir sind in
berlin-schönefeld und wir fliegen jetzt
nach wien
das ist der check in bereich hier geben
menschen ihre koffer ab
wir haben unsere koffer schon abgegeben
jetzt haben wir nur noch unser
handgepäck ja nich was ist dein
handgepäck das ist die gitarre von ihren
eine reise getan und das ist der
rucksack von jannis jetzt gehen wir zum
security check da werden unsere
gepäckstücke kontrolliert das geht in
die schlange der security checks dort
muss er sein gepäck auf einen band legen
und durchleuchten lassen
er schließt auf seinem handy janus mag
fliegen nicht
er ist kein großer fan von flugzeugen
wie fühlst du dich beim fliegen ich mag
es nicht
jetzt laufen wir zum gate
wir müssen uns beeilen denn in sieben
minuten fängt das ding an
der duty free bereich rechts noch etwas
kaufen was aber nicht unbedingt lassen
sich schon schicken sind wir schon zu
unserem geld kommt man nur wenn man
durch burger king durch solche ganz
schön ganz schöner kommerz trick wir
haben den weg zu unserem geld gefunden
er geht durch den keller
wir sind fast zu spät gekommen aber nur
fast wir haben das geld gefunden
das geht ist ein kleiner raum im keller
vom flughafen
da steigen wir jetzt in den bus und
fahren zum flugzeug
jetzt fahren wir mit dem bus zum
flugzeug
juhu ich schon total du lügst das merkte
man nicht an
das merkt man mir nicht an das merkt man
mir nicht an
das ist unser flugzeug
januar steigt in das flugzeug ein
jannis läuft die treppe hoch und sucht
seinen platz im flugzeug
das wetter ist heute ausgezeichnet ich
laufe die treppe hoch
das licht wird
wir sind gerade in wien gelandet da
unten steht die amish und guckt voller
bewunderung auf das flugzeug
ich gehe die treppe runter janus bist du
überrascht dass wir überlebt haben
nein ich bin nicht überrascht der flug
war sehr ruhig und ich habe die ganze
stunde geschlafen
jetzt sind wir in wien angekommen
janisch geht in den flughafen rhein das
flugzeug steht auf dem rollfeld die
treppe dockt an das flugzeug
er nimmt den ausgang nach wien
wichtig ist dass man den richtigen
ausgang findet janus geht jetzt richtung
wien
das ist der flughafen von wien
er sieht super nett aus und ich bin
angenehm überrascht
viel schöner als die beiden hässlichen
zu greifen in berlin ja nich bist du
froh dass wir angekommen sind ich bin
sehr froh dass wir angekommen sind und
ich habe jetzt auf einmal ein doch eine
gute laune
da habe ich aber glück gehabt ja was
machen wir jetzt jetzt wollen wir unsere
gebäcke unser gepäck das singular und
das gepäck ab unser gepäck und der
koffer und dann gehen wir wie möglich
essen
jetzt sind wir an der gepäckausgabe
da kommt mein koffer janosch nimmt
meinen koffer vom gepäckband
mittlerweile sind wir angekommen in wien
in unserer wohnung hier
wir haben das video von vom flughafen
schon geschnitten
es wird ja es ist jetzt veröffentlicht
trainiert dieses video seht es war unser
erstes video das wir mit einem handy
gefilmt haben oder einem smartphone und
wir wollen unbedingt von euch wissen ob
euch das gefallen hat ob wir mehr solche
videos drehen sollen dann schreibt uns
bitte in die kommentare und gibt uns
natürlich ein daumen nach oben
darüber freuen uns sehr wenn ihr noch
interaktive übungen machen wollt dann
werdet 1 patrick hier geht das hier
könnt ihr ein päckchen werden damit
unterstützte risi german mit nur einem
dollar pro woche zum beispiel und
bekommt jede woche ganz viele
interaktive online übungen auf eine
website und abonniert easy damen bis
bald bis nächste woche
und dann ist auch was gesagt